thank you for coming to this one there's
some great talks on over there and it's
pretty sunny upstairs so I really
appreciate it my talks about real-time
community section in large social
networks and I do that on a single
laptop so first I'm going to explain
exactly what that really terrible title
means and the data that we use is the
full Twitter network there's not trivial
to get that so I'll explain how we how
we grab it and it's 240 gigabytes 700
million accounts and 20 billion edges
and we compress that to fit on a laptop
just like this one here and that takes
him doing so I'll explain that as well
and then at the end I'll show you that
we're not just doing it for fun it does
does work it does achieve something so
I've been doing this now for two years I
started off this really great startup
called star count which is a social
media analytics startup done by Clive
hum being a weiner done who founded
dunnhumby which is the tesco clubcard
company I've now left that's why it says
a source com on my badge but I'm still
doing it because I'm a duet Imperial I'm
funded by the Royal Commission for the
exhibition of 1851 so I have an
industrial fellowship many of you are
thinking of combining education and
commercial work then I really strongly
recommend applying to the Royal
Commission they're great they fund baby
people like me every year they give you
a hundred thousand pounds to spend three
years doing research and it's not that
well known about or maybe it's a bit
better known about now oh yeah and this
whole thing is in Python obviously so
this is the problem that we started
thinking about a couple of years ago
loads of people were doing really cool
stuff with social media most of them
were looking at tweets and doing
sentiment analysis and so you'll be able
to tell your company okay what do you
think of your new products are people
mostly positive or negative but not a
lot of people were really looking at the
structure of the network and so we had
we had this problem in mind if your
essay a British company and you want to
start selling your products in Brazil
what would you need to do to do that and
any management consultant will tell you
you need to understand your customers
need to understand your competitors use
understanding distribution channels and
your mark
channels and the only real way to do
that I mean you can start googling it
but really what people do is they hire a
management consultancy and no respect
for management consultant is that
they're great but they take you know six
months and they charge you a million
pounds and it's a bit annoying if they
come back and say actually no brasil is
not going to work for you sorry so what
we thought you might be able to do given
that there are 300 million active
Twitter users across the globe is that
you could perhaps take your brand given
this on Twitter and maybe some of your
products maybe some of your star
employees or people that endorse your
brand and put them into this magic
Twitter machine and this out out would
come what people who like your stuff
also like in Brazil so that was the idea
so could we tell what your Brazilian
fans media titles of choice I'll or
their influences which footballers do
they follow and then we know how you can
launch your product in this new market
so that was that was the big idea we
want to do this in real time because
what for the same reason that we all
love working in Python it's a Python for
me it connects my brain to the machine
and back again I try something out it
doesn't work imma try something again
and then it doesn't work again but I'm
instantly I get that feedback and I can
work really really fast i used to be a
C++ programmer and it was it's just not
evil anymore once you start doing Python
it's not no fun to go back to see
because you have to wait and so I wanted
to build a product that was like that
that was instantaneous you put your what
you want in doesn't quite work you try
something else you get the feedback and
the reason we wanted to want a single
laptop is because when working with
Hadoop and spark and I'm sure loads of
people here have it's completely the way
the industry is going and most people
will stand up and tell you how amazing
that those tools are and how seemed to
say they get them to work that's a lie
at least it's a live my experience
they're really really hard this is my
stack trace like from last week there's
an error in there I ran this ten times i
get 10 different errors i don't
understand what's going on i have like a
engineer who has to fix all these
problems for me it's just not it's not
easy to get cluster computing working
there's a huge amount of complexity so
if you can do something on a single
machine
and that's that's at least eight you
should start so this is what the whole
thing a very high level we fought might
look like you get your Twitter handles
of things you know you put them into
this Twitter machine that gets out all
of the similar stuff so you might put
ten things in you might get four
thousand things out of that second box
and then you take those four thousand
things and you structure them in some
way so you can look at these are all the
media titles these are all the
influencers these are all your
competitors and then you look at you
make a pretty ish picture like that and
then if you don't like what you see you
maybe you hover over that bit and put
that in back in the front and you get a
new picture so it allows you to explore
this huge world of 300 million accounts
interactively so the first thing is to
define what we mean by similar and for
us the obvious similarity measure on
twitter is shared followers so if i if
there's a blog out there that loads of
people that follow my company also
follow then it makes sense that that
blog is important to me and that maybe i
should be talking to that blog so you
can measure the number of shared
followers but the problem doing that is
that counts like justin bieber have like
a hundred million followers so they'll
come up as being really important to
everything so you need to normalize it
in some way and then the natural way to
normalize these things is using
something called the Jaccard similarity
measure and the jackal assimilation
measure basically takes that number of
shared followers and divide it by the
total number of followers of the two
things it's the intersection divided by
the union right before I had this job we
used to work for an investment bank and
after that I used to work in defense so
you still used to have financial data or
sensor data and then I started working
with social data and it's horrific it's
like so much worse than any structure
data set you can imagine because there
are these entities that exist in the
social world because it's real humans or
not real human sometimes that you just
do not expect to see so Twitter is full
of robotic accounts accounts created
that run completely autonomously to do
loads of crazy stuff there are also an
enormous number of people running what's
called the follow back strategy so if
you have a Twitter account you've
probably been followed by someone that
has 10,000 followers and follows 10,000
people and thirty percent of people that
get followed by that person will follow
them back so what guys are doing is
they're following a thousand thousand
people a week 304 and back there bending
off all the ones that don't and they're
doing it again so you can get like a
huge amounts of Twitter followers that
way but doesn't say anything about what
you're interested in or what you like so
you need to try and ignore those people
there's a massive massive market for
paid followers so i might get in trouble
for saying this if anyone from Twitter's
here but so Justin Bieber has 70 million
followers he doesn't he has 20 million
followers and he's bought 50 million
followers same with Katy Perry same with
Lady gaga they're also a ton of fake
accounts so the way the way a lot of
cheap follower sellers work is they have
this enormous conveyor belt they set up
a fake account they follow l'eau de
l'eau loads people spin it to the back
another one comes out follows those are
people this is my current favorite
bottom Twitter it's the International
Space Station bot so what happens if you
follow this bot I don't know how it
knows where you are but it somehow does
and when it's overhead it sends you a
direct message on twitter saying look
I'm there and if you're outside and it's
dark maybe you can see the International
Space Station it's cool and this is an
example of some of the junk that's all
over Twitter so these four accounts they
look pretty legitimate they've got like
money threads staff they've got kind of
normal names then you look at the
description then it they're all the same
description it's all twits it building a
Twitter zip code infrastructure for
consistent public use I don't know why
someone's made these maybe someones
experimenting but stuff like this really
messes up your data so you need to be
you need to be aware of it this graph
here I've taken all 700 million Twitter
accounts and I've plotted the number
that follow each number of people so on
the left there that's the people that
follow no one on the right someone
follows two million people and we
expected this to be a straight line this
is actually a log-log plot so there's
loads of theories and social networks
you get loads of log log plots because
power laws look like a log log in the
social
when you plot like this and this is
really weird well you can probably see
it from there but this rabbit thing
that's just sitting on top of the graph
so which we didn't expect to see and the
reason there's a that thing is because
that is at two thousand and you can only
follow two thousand people on twitter
before twitter twitter blocked you so
there are these these kind of factories
that are selling fake followers they
spin up an account the account cells
2000 follows and then twitter blocks it
so it goes to another one and that's
what all of that all of that is that's
all manufactured accounts okay so that's
that's the basic setup and some problems
with Twitter how do you then go about
getting all of twitter well you need you
need three things so you need access
tokens whenever you click log in with
twitter on an app that's what you're
doing you're giving that app one access
token then you also need some engineers
to build the thing and as we found out
you need a pretty damn good internet
connection so when we set about doing
this we had we had three apps we
actually the fouls and access tokens
which is more than most people have but
you can easily get ten if you have some
mates and a few email accounts so you
can have a go at this and we looked for
libraries and we found a library really
cool I be called tweet pea which is a
Python library for downloading twitter
stuff and we have we ran it on a single
machine before let's try and get all
atwitter and it was going to take us
something like a year so okay well
that's that's not really going to work
what's going on there and the problem is
that when when you run an app like that
it makes a request to Twitter and then
just sits there and does absolutely
nothing while twitter at some point
response maybe two seconds later so
almost all of your processing time is
just waiting for Twitter to get back to
you so if I ok what we'll do great plan
is well have lately loads of those so we
had 200 of these on separate threads
running at the same time if all that but
that'll run 200 times faster but it
doesn't so if you know anything well a
lot of that pie for maybe you'll know
that there's a global interpreter lock
in Python so when you run multi-threaded
code it's not actually running in power
ll because it all has to respond back to
this global interpreter lock that's how
you get the interactivity but it means
that you can you don't get that
parallelization so it didn't it didn't
really work but at this point we
discover they're actually three distinct
paradigms for doing this kind of thing
there's the one on the left there which
is what I tried to start with which is
just having one thread then you can have
multiple threads but the magic really
happens on the right with asynchronous
programming so high phone has this
really cool library called twisted which
gives you an asynchronous programming
reactor loop and why what a synchronous
programming does is it it doesn't wait
anymore so when you send off your
request you don't wait two seconds you
just end up firing off like thousands
and thousands of requests and when
something comes back the reactor knows
just to grab it process it and keep
firing firing firing so when we switch
from 200 threads to one asynchronous
Fred we actually crash the internet of
our building so we were in the BBC annex
it was really really annoying for
everyone working with us I've got some
tips for asynchronous programming and
platform because I spent three months
doing this and it was a horrible three
months of my life so the first thing is
read a book and actually read read that
book by Dave petty coalesce it's free
it's at cuando calm it takes about 10
hours to read so the number of times I'd
like we'd one part of it and then be
like oh I can't be bothered to read it
I'm just going to try and hack along and
that's what I recommend doing normally
when your program right you program you
hack along something doesn't work you go
on Stack Overflow you find the answer
yukiko that's like the way to learn
programming it's not with asynchronous
programming to read a book and my second
big tip for asynchronous programming is
draw draw out because you have these
everything goes the wrong way up do you
have a reactor that fires things are
back the wrong way up the stack so you
can't debug in a normal way and things
don't go through the code in a linear
fashion they can move so you need a
picture which it's really really hard to
debug and I what's going on so this is
the architecture we ended up with each
one of those clients is a twisted
asynchronous thingy they all scream at
Twitter and this guy at the top the
server is telling
and what watch request to ask for and it
also has a queue of access tokens so
every time an access token gets burnt
out the client says I've used up this
one it goes to the back of a big queue
we put a lock on it for 15 minutes and
then it can flow back through again this
managed to get all atwitter in two days
okay so that's how you you get the data
240 gigabytes full Twitter network 700
million accounts 20 billion edges that
doesn't fit in memory on a laptop at
least not a laptop that's going to be
built for the next thousand years
thousand maybe a bit of a big big shot
there but not at the moment so you need
to compress it now what you normally do
when you want to compress data the first
thing to try is just sample it but you
can't sample network data because no
point these points represent humans or
BOTS or the things that are unique
there's no iid nurse at all there and
you can't just you there's no way to
know which vertices to choose or which
edges to cut off and you can't follow
edges because then you just find like
the UK and you're trying to learn about
everything so you can't sample basically
but there is this magical thing called
me and hashing which is invented by
Android broda in two thousand he's now a
Google senior fellow so he's pretty
awesome and he came up with this idea
where you can Matt you can convert
enormous sets so each one of those
things might be Justin Bieber with 100
million followers and you convert them
into a fixed length array of integers
and x just comparing this is justin
bieber and this is katy perry you just
compare element-wise so these ones are
the same not the same same same not the
same so three were the same there were
five in total so the jacquard estimate
is three fifths so it's super easy and
that that kind of thing takes
nanoseconds on a computer instead of
trying to compare two things there are a
hundred million elements this takes you
know a second or two or longer this is
probably the most boring part of my talk
coming up next it's five slides I'm
trying to explain how min hashing works
please bear with me
so this picture here is a Twitter world
where there are only eight Twitter
accounts and I'm trying to compare a
company and a blog and here the company
and blogger both followed by the first
Twitter account not only my followed by
the second that both followed by the
third only the company's followed by the
fall for the bow followed by the fifth
non by the sixth both by the seventh and
only the blog is followed by the ape and
to take the min hash this this guy you
just take the minimum value where each
one has a follower so one and one and
then what you do is you randomly permute
all of the accounts wrong way and take
the minimum again so now the company's
minimum is at one and the blog's minimum
is at three now you keep doing that so I
randomly muted it again companies
minimums at three blogs minimums at four
and again and again and that seems like
that seems to me completely random but
it's not so the probability of the blog
in the company having the same min hash
value is exactly the chance that you hit
one of these guys where they both agree
before you hit one of those guys or one
of those guys ok and the number of these
guys is the intersection and that Plus
that Plus that is the union so the
probability of any one of those min
hashes being the same getting a
collision is that number and that is
just that so I've got no idea how
Android Broder came up with this and
what he was thinking about but it's
awesome and it's used all over the
Internet there's a bit of a trade-off
between the length of the min hashes and
the accuracy and and the performance so
the longer the hashes you have the more
memory you need the longer it takes but
the more accuracy you get so we did we
try this for four hundred thousand
different combinations of people and
actually we worked as its base strictly
a binomial distribution anyway so we
didn't need to do this but around a
thousand min hashes the whole data set
would fit in four gigabytes so roughly
Ram of
a pretty rubbish laptop and the arrow is
only 0.001 jackal space which it turns
out for our problem is absolutely fine
so once you've got them in hashes it's
really really quick to compare and get
jacquard estimates but getting them is a
super pain because you have 20 billion
edges and you're tackling a thousand
hashes for every single edge so you've
got like 20 trillion calculations and
when we originally did that it took six
days in pandas just trying the first
thing we could think about so what we
ended up doing is coding it all in
siphon so siphon is the Python sea
bridge project hyphen is completely
rubbish a loops so you should never
really be doing big loops in Python but
siphon is basically see and it's altima
looped and there are a few tricks you
can do in siphon so you can you can have
strongly typed variables and the reason
pythons all full it loops is because it
checks the bounds on the arrays every
single time and you can turn that off in
siphon and you can also stick your
raising integers memory if you want to
do something really quickly siphon is
absolutely the way to do it and I
strongly strongly recommend anything
you're doing when stuff takes too long
profile your code so the profiler I use
is built into Python pie chart with my
favorite ID but there are there's loads
and loads of 3 PI from profilers and
prune and L prune a built-in type IFEM
they're also great so totally profile
your code and this book is the source I
think like these guys are both speaking
here this book is incredible if you want
to do fasting fastenings in Python get
it read it so now we've got the data its
compressed it fits on in memory of a
single laptop but we still need to query
it in real time so real time means less
than a quarter of a second for me you've
got a bit of a problem because there are
roughly a million of these these things
I've been hashed so I had min hash the
million most interesting accounts on
Twitter the ones the largest million and
so if you want to put 10 accounts in and
compare every single one of them to
every single one of those things you're
looking at 10 million different
comparisons
which is hard to do in the quarter of a
second and the solution to that problem
is something called locality sensitive
hashing so the way locality sensitive
hashing works with min hashing is you
you kind of band up the min hashes and
hash each one of those bands and then
into a little box in here and things
that agree on a whole band go into the
same box and yeah that was that wasn't a
very good sir description it's quite an
involved subjects I can talk about it
afterwards van was really interested but
they key point about locality sensitive
hashing is its constant time roughly
similar look up so it gets you from
something not real time to something
real time with a little bit of error and
so we have this system in the end where
you put in a product and brand handles
you fire it into locality sensitive
hashing outcome may be four thousand
things that are pretty closely related
to your products and your brand's and
your people and then we put those four
thousand things through another great
library call i graph which is available
in C I think it's written and see but we
use the Python version there's a cool
platform wrapper of it and that gets you
pictures like this kind of thing so it
does community detection we use an
algorithm called walk trap cool and
that's that's a real-time querying now
on the full Twitter graph so again 700
million accounts 20 billion edges
real-time querying on a laptop now
that's that's all great but no way in
anything I've said have I given any real
indication that this works at all and
it's quite hard to to prove that
something that kind of process works
because I'm saying right i put in a
company and some other people and then i
get out things that are related that
it's difficult to imagine a scientific
evaluation of that process so what we
actually did is we went on wikipedia and
we tried to match every twitter handle
we could to a Wikipedia page and
wikipedia pages have a loaded tags
attached to them and so we extracted
these tags and attach them to Twitter to
Twitter handles
and we did this for loads of things so
we did this for things tagged with
travel we did it for models we did it
for MMA fighters various sportsmen
athletes it we even did it for porn
stars and then we put 30 people from
each of these groups into our machine
and we looked at how how many from the
group came out again at the other side
so the ideal situation is the put 30 in
and you get the whole rest of the group
help some people have done things
similar in the past and they've
identified the state-of-the-art
algorithm for doing that and it's an
algorithm called personalized page rank
so these charts personalized page rank
is the red line ours there's two
variants of what we did and there the
yellow and blue lines and this measures
the total recall so a recall of one
would be an ultimate win almost
impossible but the takeaway here is that
we're higher than the red line give it
more flavor to that I zoomed in on that
sounded like that weren't weird can
everyone hear me still okay a zoomed in
on one of the one of the communities
that I thought people would be able to
understand it's the alcohol community so
we again we put 30 things that were
labeled as being alcohol brands in and
this is what comes out so we clustered
it using this walk trap algorithm and
it's not really a big surprise but is
still cool that it works the alcohol is
clustered into four different categories
so in the bottom left there there's beer
the bottom right cider the top left is
spirits and the top right is wine and
we've zoomed in on the cider and just
pulled out some Twitter logos hopefully
just to convince people that this thing
really works I'm not just drawing pretty
pictures I wanted to do this with
pornstars but some of their pictures
were not appropriate
so I also looked at the u.s. Republican
Party so I put into the machine this
time all of the now former candidates
for leader of the u.s. Republican Party
and I wanted to see if there were
factions within the u.s. Republican
Party so does it split in two major bits
or the other two factions I wasn't
really sure and so here this is the this
is the mainstay these are all the major
Republicans this here is some media
titles and some lesser Republicans
governors and things instead of senators
up here is Ben Carson's carson ben
Carson he's a I don't you know he's like
a doctor who tried to become president
but he's not really a mainstream
Republican and up here is Donald Trump
so Donald Trump is barely connected to
the Republican Party and he's actually
his only connection is this one and that
is megan kelly who actually really hates
him so he's only connected to the
Republican Party by someone who despises
him okay so what we've done then is
we've downloaded the full Twitter graph
which is huge 240 gigabytes would
compressed it to fit on on a laptop so
four gigabytes or a little bit more than
eight gigabyte laptop would be fine
we're showing you can query that data
structure in real time so you can within
a quarter of a second you get results
back you can iterate them get them in
again iterate them people that star
can't use this and then we shown how you
can cluster those using walk trap and
get interpretable pictures out which can
tell you something about the real world
I owe a debt to a couple of guys at star
count for this presentation donal semi
who's a really cool those scientists
there did all of the all of this life
and stuff that he got them in hashing
down from six days to an hour which I
didn't think would be possible and Josh
Larry Kramer who actually spoke here
last year did some of the slides I don't
know if I'm allowed this next slide i'm
going to try anyway so i work at a
source now we're hiring speak to me
afterwards if you're interested in my
loud to do that
okay kids right and that's the that's
the end of my talk thank you so much for
listening thanks um so I just wanted to
clarify after you found the neighborhood
using locality sensitive hashing what
were the connections between the members
of the neighborhood with a follower
connections or were they associations
like Jaccard similarity yeah so that
that's really really good question I
completely missed out that bit of the
talk because it would have been too long
but what we actually do is we then we
take these four thousand people and then
we use them in hash signatures again to
reconstruct a weighted sub network and
then we then we do community detection
on the weighted sub graph which is why
we use walked out because it's really
good with a weighted networks so do you
apply any kind of specification rule to
prune edges from that work well we said
we don't need to because it's only four
thousand vertices oh yes you're right it
is fully connected but walk trap works
with fully connect across sorry thanks
very much for your fuel talk I just
wanted like in terms of Twitter and the
rate API maybe I missed something there
but how did you handle that kind of
aspect of it because I believe that
their rate limiting your according to
developer api's yeah so it a super rate
limit we had three commercial apps we
collected a thousand access tokens we
put them in this big queue and just spam
through them all okay right and then
eventually I guess the tokens expired
and that's when you put it at the end
and went then wait five hours or however
15 minutes 15 minutes yeah so what the
way it works is you I don't never go
back to that picture it seems to be
stuck on that one
oh here we go okay so this this guy here
manages a queue of a thousand access
tokens and it gives them to these guys
when they scream out when they're when
they're done and they say okay we've
burnt out that one and this sends a flag
back here which says put a lock on that
for 15 minutes yeah and he just you just
spin through the queue yeah we tried
doing something very similar Facebook
something yeah Facebook's hard as well
icepick slave let's talk about that when
you do the whole process the local a
sensitive hashing how much time does it
take you to do the indexing and how much
time that they take to compute to the
parallel no power like the similarities
so the whole thing runs in under a
quarter of a second sorry the whole the
whole thing runs in under a quarter of a
second so you you choose your seeds you
put them in you hit return and like in
real time it returns that those pictures
those kind of graphs to index the lsh
table takes half an hour okay okay thank
you
and on on this slide do you have any
tips for you mentioned I was putting
tricky debugging asynchronous twisted
apps yummy tips for debugging the app
and deploying to multiple servers yes so
the main the main tip I heard was so we
had this picture we had loads of these
pictures for every little bit of it
because you never you never know when
the entry point is into the code because
when you get a response back it just
triggers off a new chain of execution
which is really really confusing when
you're trying to debug so we had this
picture of this kind of loop of how
Oliver how the code was blowing and that
really helped us out so we have other
pictures as well which show so in a
synchronous program you have callbacks
and you have error box and you if you
like satisfy an error back you can go
into the callback chain again so having
those drawn out with like little boxes
showing where which error back leads to
which call back I think is absolutely
key okay thank you very much no more
questions thank you the great talk